el cáncer en el intestino grueso se
llama cáncer colorrectal las partes del
intestino grueso son el colon el recto y
el canal anal
la mayoría de los casos de cáncer
colorrectal comienza en el colon en
pequeños grupos de células llamados
pólipos la mayoría de los pólipos son
benignos lo que significa que contienen
células anormales que no son cancerosas
y no se diseminarán al resto del cuerpo
solo están presentes en la delgada capa
de tejido que recubre el interior del
intestino si las células anormales se
convierten en células cancerosas el
pólipo puede agrandarse e invadir más
profundamente la pared del intestino
grueso
si no se trata las células cancerosas
pueden ingresar al torrente sanguíneo y
diseminarse a los ganglios linfáticos
cercanos con el tiempo estas células
pueden llegar a otros órganos y formar
más tumores existe mayor riesgo de
contraer cáncer colorrectal si tiene
antecedentes familiares de cáncer
colorrectal
tiene pólipos de colon tiene 50 años o
más es obeso
fuma cigarrillos
no realiza actividad física
bebe demasiado alcohol
o tiene una enfermedad que inflama el
colon como colitis ulcerosa o enfermedad
de crohn
los síntomas del cáncer colorrectal
pueden incluir un cambio en los hábitos
intestinales como diarrea estreñimiento
o heces más delgadas de lo normal sangre
roja oscura brillante en las heces
sentirse incapaz de vaciar el intestino
dolor de vientre hinchazón o calambres
pérdida de peso sin motivo sentirse
débil o muy cansado y vómitos
es importante saber que estos síntomas
pueden ser causados por afecciones
distintas al cáncer de colon y es
posible tener cáncer colorrectal sin
presentar ningún síntoma especialmente
en las primeras etapas se tiene
preguntas sobre el cáncer colorrectal
habla con su proveedor de atención
médica